and then I met a girl when I was like 19
lost my virginity you know and then I
was on felony p and she held me down is
that TV show no oh but like it's a
felony P oh felony probation probation
was cool it's cool you're a criminal
it's cool it's cool no it's not cool I
don't like my minerals man it's not cool
dude all right but I was with her so
what'd you do I was with her for like
seven years what'd you do man that's a
crime what did I do yeah why I've never
been like I got jumped by like 16 dudes
so I drove a car through the crowd
oh that oh that's not bad I like that I
like that no no no dude you know that's
fine not good with that like they tried
to him you're not Philippi in my eyes no
they tried to hit my phone yeah and I
was like how about I hit you with this
Mitsubishi monster
yeah [__] yeah dude yeah good for you
dude but now I'm now I'm older and when
I see like a Park Mitsubishi Montero I'm
like that's a big ass car yeah yeah yeah
yeah but don't [__] with my car with a
tire iron so yeah don't [__] with my boy
every action has a reaction exactly
right so anyway so um what was the worst
way your dad hit you
oh man yo this sounds really really wild
but he had this rubber alligator that
was just heavy just heavy yeah enough
that was Heavy rubber so it would bend
but snap but the scales were dumb hard
so he would purposely hit us with this
alligator wow and he hit us so hard that
my skin would be bruised in the shape of
the alligator scales wow that's uh wild
and then but where do you get that toy
and then how old were you when that
happened
like I mean I don't like 12 12 to 60. I
I know I exactly yeah Golf Club I can
feel myself getting uncomfortable though
we gotta get off my dad hitting me I can
feel my neck getting uncomfortable all
right
it makes you feel better my mom would be
good but you know we'll move on we'll
move I'll start yo now I'll tell you
something now that I'm older I can tell
when I get anxiety yeah I'm like and I'm
not one of those like I'm shut down to
I'm not too but I'll just be out loud
like yo I got anxiety the body keeps the
score yeah it does it does um my my mom
if it makes you feel any better she was
very creative with her torture tactics
she would take a banana peel after she
would like eat it slowly and like just
lock eyes with me and then she would
just whip my face
banana peels
that's pretty creative but also just
like insulting it's insulting yeah yeah
yeah that's that's that [__] would
bother me too my mom would have me and
my brother slap each other
no really come on yeah oh my God that's
the original what is that new new the
powers yeah your mom is the original
Dana White the power slab having us
power slap each other but what did we
learn from all that
no
that we're not going to perpetuate that
behavior
to our children right yeah I'm
definitely the alligator no I don't have
kids but if you did I wouldn't use the
alligator what would you use nothing
right you know I thought the one
punishment that was really good here all
right let me hear it maybe that's a good
one and I thought it was funny because
it was like he also tied race into it in
a like self-deprecating he'd have me
purposely kneel on a bag of rice like
you know oh my God and just like I could
have done the floor
let's throw extra salt to the wound do
some [__] [__] get up on this Coco Rose
God I talk about it all the time on the
show ours was rock salt yeah yeah
broccoli would start to seep the salt
yeah oh yes oh my gosh how about did you
guys ever do the books yeah the books
yeah books is fun books is fun yo my dad
used to if my brothers or I were
annoying and we have photos of this yeah
there's photos where it's my dad
watching a sports event on TV and us in
a horse dance next to the television
we all wanted a watch yeah we'd just be
in a horse dance with our backs turned
to the television yeah as my dad watched
it yeah and you would explain this stuff
to like Americans they have no they have
no idea that it's going on yeah right
and we're living in this these isolated
like it's like we're in a different
country almost I always get this like
that didn't happen to you bad success I
know I hate it like shut the [__] up you
I saw I was like this to my kid like if
they weren't listening and I was having
real issues yeah I mean you like the
Knicks yeah yeah I like the Knicks but
we sit down let's like order food get
ready for the next game starts
immediately a tip off all right turn
your back to the game and stand in a
horse dance
I would not [__] around like anymore all
right well I learned my lesson all right
right